[Música]
a 35 km de parís en el valle de yugos
este castillo nos sumerge en el corazón
de la historia de francia
propiedad de los objetos desde 1712 la
visita pone en escena durante cuatro
siglos
el extraordinario destino de esta
familia de aristócratas
o la señorita o la joven
los visitantes siempre son acogidos por
el propietario en persona el hi françois
de objeto y décimo marqués de la familia
siempre me gusta este castillo cuando
iba a las librerías mira todos los
libros sobre reyes las reinas en cuanto
se hablaba de bretón lo ponía feliz veía
la importancia de los ancestros que fui
aprendiendo cada vez más entonces para
mí no es una carga es una alegría
entre los ancestros de henrry françois
de objeto y hay ilustres personajes que
sirvieron a grandes monarcas
esto corresponde más o menos al
ministerio del interior
ministros diplomáticos e incluso
científicos tales como y mil de châtelet
fue la primera que tradujo al francés
los trabajos del físico isaac newton a
lo largo de la visita la familia de
objetos se descubre a través de escenas
reconstruidas que brindan alegría a los
visitantes
la particularidad es que permaneció muy
animado en muchos testimonios muchas
fotos me parece interesante con respecto
a otros castillos que visitan
la otra particularidad del castillo es
que celebra los cuentos del poeta salvo
una elección en nada relacionada con el
azar y que se explica una vez más por la
historia de la familia de objetos
vuelo desde habrá hecho y tuvo como
brazo derecho a salvo al comienzo de la
carrera de pegó este último trabajo de
la administración de luis 14 durante
toda su vida fue protegido de holberg
después de las finanzas trabajó con la
cultura y la literatura por supuesto
pero escribió cuentos que todo el mundo
conoce tan sólo al final de su vida se
escribió a los 63 años
wason
piel de asno barba azul cenicienta
caperucita roja todos estos cuentos han
sobrevivido a las épocas
[Música]
lejos cuentos de pegó existían antes de
pegó pero se les llama a los cuentos de
pegó porque es él quien los puso en
literatura en la corte del rey en los
salones parisinos y fueron editados en
francés lo que era muy moderno para la
época cuando existían en el campo desde
siempre
en las dependencias del castillo los
sainetes
del mismo
dan vida a todos estos relatos que me
hicieron nuestra infancia el jefe de
orquesta de este espectáculo de sonido e
iluminación nos conduce tras bastidores
de su más reciente creación barba azul
barba azul es un señor muy rico y quise
hacer eso en un espíritu barroco con una
gran composición central arreglamos la
mesa aquí un gran banquete acción
instalan gto instale para realizar esta
escena impresionante fueron necesarios
cuatro meses de trabajo y un presupuesto
de 50.000 euros
y
desconectivos la idea es tener varios
niveles de lectura que sea a la vez muy
estético y al mismo tiempo sintamos
emociones y sorpresa miedo misterio
inquietud y espero ovación para el
público
cenicienta el gato con botas' o piel de
asno
en total son siete cuentos puestos en
escena en el castillo de objetos
pero el espectáculo no para aquí
continúa en las tablas
toc toc toc
los sabores
ese día natal y almeida la cuentista del
castillo cuenta de la historia del gato
con botas'
en nuestra historia el gato era el más
astuto el más inteligente de todos los
gatos este asunto felino logra hacer
pasar a su amo un simple molinero por un
personaje importante cercano al rey
y como siempre con sal pero el cuento
termina con una moraleja
lo que quiere decir que el hábito no
hace al monje
sigue siendo de actualidad hoy en día no
se usan las mismas palabras pero las
moralejas siguen existiendo
el hecho de no fiarse de las apariencias
el hecho de que el amor transforma todo
en algo de ello y maravilloso
abriendo sus puertas al público en los
años 1960 la familia de objetos salvo su
castillo de la quiebra una elección
crucial de la que su actual propietario
no se arrepiente
mi pasión era este castillo era la obra
de mi vida salvar un castillo de la
familia
mágico encantador impresionante por su
historia y los personajes ilustres que
lo habitaron el castillo de objetos
atrae cada año a cerca de 120 mil
visitantes
[Música]